with the rise of AI the job market is
Shifting fast here are three things you
can practice for free on Khan Academy to
Future proof your job skills number one
is critical thinking while AI can handle
vast amounts of data in the end it's
humans who have to interpret it and come
to a decision learn more about decision
making and what goes into critical
thinking so you can handle complex
situations in any career number two is
creativity while AI can do some creative
tasks it can replace human creativity
practice your storytelling so that you
can express yourself come to develop new
ways of thinking and come up with ideas
that might change can't generate number
three is learning agility this is your
ability to acquire and develop new
skills at any age luckily we can all
improve our learning abilities with
learning science principles like growth
mindset developing these skills will
help you acquire what you need to know
in a world that's going to be changed by
the future of AI if you want to practice
these skills make sure you try our new
AI tutor kanmigo who can personalize
your experience as you develop the
skills needed to succeed in the future
of AI